الخطوط الحمر في نزاع روسيا واوكرانيا
بدات تنهار الواحده والاخر وامام اعين من
امنوا بان الحرب قد تحمل بعض الاخلاق
القادره على منع الفوضى الشامله لم يخرج
من مخباه في بدايه الحرب الا بعد الحصول
على ضمانات من روسيا بانها لن تستهدفه كما
قال رئيس وزراء اسرائيل الاسبق نفطاليبنت
الشاهد على الاتفاق وامريكا بدورها رفضت
مرارا ضرب روسيا بسلاحها وحتى استهداف
وزير الدفاع روسيا او رئيس اركانها في
اوكرانيا الا ان كييف التي تخوض حرب بقاء
لم يتبقى لها الكثير لتخسره وفيتو الحلفاء
مرهون باستخدام سلاحهم والحل لم تحمله الا
اسلحه الروس انفسهم
قبل اشهر
271 مسيره صوفيتيه سبق ظهورها المسيرات
الحديثه حلقت نحو الهدف على علو امطار
قليله في تحدي الرادارات ضربت اوكرانيا
قاعده انجلز على بعد اقل من 200 كيلومتر
من موسكو ثم قاعده اخرى في اليازان
الاضرار في كل مره لا تحسب بالخسائر
الماديه بل بوقعها المعنوي على الروس
الذين لا يفهموا الاوكراني حتى الان كيف
انهم لا يشعرون بالحرب على ابوابهم في
مرحله ثانيه شرعت اوكرانيا في استهداف
روسيا بمسيره سقط معظمها بعيدا عن موسكو
مسيرات تبدو غير متطوره لكنها فرضت على
الروس نشر انظمه الدفاع على مباني العاصمه
الشاهقه من معارك خرسون وزبولوجيا تنقل
اوكرانيا المعركه داخل روسيا فيبريانسك
على الحدود وفي موسكو وضواحيها قبل ان
تستهد ف الكريم او ربما بوتين نفسه حسب
الروايه الرسميه الروسيه فيما رجحت وسائل
اعلام تنفيذ الهجوم بمسيره تجاريه صينيه
انطلقت من مكان غير بعيد عن الحادث فهل هي
بدايته هجوم اوكراني ام محاوله لافساد عيد
النصر على روسيا الا ان الاكيده هو تداعيه
الهجوم الذي قد يدخل الحرب مرحله حاول
الجميع تفاديها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات